kyle schwarber will make his socks debut
tonight for a ball club that really
needs the spark yeah the wait it's
finally over been waiting about two
weeks but they got their legitimate
left-handed power bat did they ever this
guy is having a great year nick pavetta
8-5
and he's beating the orioles in both of
his starts against them this season and
here's number 31 that's doing it all by
the way career high 19-game hit streak
pavetta full-count pitch to mullins
lined into right field and chalk up
another one that hit streak is now 20
games
one two and he throws it away mullins on
his way to second
and he's in on
an error from nick pavetta
waved at and missed on a curveball he
didn't get it
and a strikeout for pavetta
trey mancini steps in right side against
pavetta
31 to come back or off the glove
misdirected to bogarts a little bobble
to throw
and in time he recovered
safely down to third mullins but two
down so two guys got a glove on it i
can't believe he was he was out at first
base
oh one
oh i pop up behind third down the line
denver's bow guards for dugo and xander
will take it
and pivette is out of the inning little
shaky but strands too
spencer watkins first time in fenway
though he's lost three in a row they
didn't score him a lot of runs one two
three
actually his pitched what four five and
two thirds at six
sixth is the longest of his career or at
least ties the longest of his career
numbers aren't bad
little dribbler here franco went for the
bare hand but he cannot come up with it
and [ __ ] is safe should be a base hit it
probably will be do or die there by
franco and he just doesn't get it done
xander bogart's at 304 is 17 home runs
he's driven in 60.
hammered center field mullins back in
the corner has room and makes the catch
well the triangle
wow hit it a long way
boy do i know that triangle well
well it's 4 20. well baltimore is a home
run here it's into the triangle and we
talked about mullins can you know win so
many games in so many different ways
here's you know ball hit really well but
just an out because of
outstanding defense
up
left field
santander out there
and the red sox are retired
head to the second orioles and red sox
no score
severino franco and mateo for the
orioles in the second and a 2-2
in there strike three no argument
back to the heater love that fastball
right there hello
one more pitch slap to short
bogart's on target two fast doubts in
the second inning
swing and a miss he struck him out
down goes mateo fast inning for pavetta
bottom of the second hunter renfro to
lead things off schwarber next
and that went tagged on the line at the
right field opposite field single for
hunter renfro is on with the second red
sox knock tonight against watkins
so now kyle schwarber to make his red
sox debut
hasn't played since the second of july
here he comes
and he's going to take ball four
to start his red sox career first and
second nobody out
opportunity to do some damage
base hit past the diving martin
it's so hard renfo has to pull in the
third stop there
that was on the button and the bases are
loaded with nobody out duran needs a big
hit desperately
and he's got himself a base hit
that'll bring in renfro schwarber to
third
and we'll stop right there and the red
sox grab the one nothing lead and duran
hit it right on the button bobby dalbeck
now at 46 runs batted in had five two
nights ago
and that one spanked toward the wall
that catches the top of that ledge
one run in
two runs in he's into second base with a
double
and that one he really hit hard and the
red sox lead it three to nine that was
an absolute cookie that he crushed top
of the order in hernandez with an
infield single in the first inning
kiki strokes that one into left field
santander back at the track duran
tagging up he's going to advance home
he is in to score
red sox lead it four to nothing over
baltimore
and it's a drive out towards right field
heading back out and just past the pole
that's a home run
richie martin with the shortest possible
home run you could find at fenway park
vindication for some of the short ones
that they saw at camden yards over the
last week a solo shot off pavetta leads
off the third gets the orioles on the
board they cut the lead four to one two
up two down in the third in front of
schwarber who walked and scored in the
second inning
he takes another walk and here's
plawecki base hitting the run in the
second
hard hit out of the range of mancini
coming on in to score schwarberg
duran take it out for second they'll be
on at second and third red sox get
another one
on top five to one yeah back to back
curveballs he's on this one
he's on this one you know he's seen it
before he's swung and missed and
beautiful thing down and in he gets it
busting high cheese
oh he was ready for it deep drive right
field renfro back track and wall leaping
up he's got it
that was gonna get out of here
renfro got there in time and saved a
home run
that makes up for the pesky piece right
there because that's a bridge ball
he got away with a fastball he tried to
come in after he thrown two two good
pitches on the corner fastball there he
barreled it i thought this ball was gone
and it probably was if he wasn't there
it falls over the fence
caught on and missed that curveball lead
him up hayes never could find it and two
down
one two
right past them 96 miles an hour
back-to-back strikeouts for nick pavetta
alexander bogarts will be next
high flying to left
santander's back he's looking up now
looking up and that ball is out of here
home run xander bogarts it was up there
all night
and finally landed on that ledge and a
red sox lead at six to one i thought
there's candy corn fly ball
you know lazy fly ball to left field it
never came down till it hit the ledge
one man out
nice diving play devils goes in the
second again and out on the play
a sprawling stab by raphael he really
had no business getting it out there
that ball was behind him he corralled it
somehow
sprawling
one man gone for bobby dawbeck good
count for him the 3-1 pitch
center field deep mullins back back
there looking up it's gone
well give him another one against
baltimore and the red sox are on time
7-1 how about bobby d huh
and a scorcher off the scoreboard for
two rbi and then he goes bridge gets a
piece of cheese three to one he goes to
work on it dead central here's how to
rent roll
oh he's gonna sting this one high d
drive and kiss that one goodbye
that got totally out of fenway in a
heartbeat i got your change up i've got
your change up right here
77 piece goes way back news 20th home
run
he leaned on it doesn't he can lean on
stuff
big man leaning
second and third two down and a 2-2
swag
and a nice way to end it the red sox
eight
the orioles won red sox behind pavetta
and three home runs knock off baltimore
eight to one
you